the gyro can experience I mean one of
the sadder features of our our moment
given all our the joy of reveling in
each other's humanity and music and so
forth is that you know you got impending
ecological catastrophe hmm escalating
nuclear catastrophe economic catastrophe
the grotesque wealth inequality all
around the world spiritual catastrophe
in terms of intensifying forms of
depression suicide wasted lies lack of
self-respect not believing in oneself
and thinking that the only way you can
really make it is by imitating the
mainstream forms of conformity hmm and
in the political catastrophes of
right-wing movements all around the
world
yeah and by right-wing movements what I
mean is to rule a big money big military
and then scapegoat the most vulnerable
and try to convince the most vulnerable
that it's their fault that they're in
the subordinate positions that they are
rather than giving them a fair chance
you see and that's the makings of new
forms of fascism and so on you see and
you say to yourself you know how do we
hold on to some sense of hope and there
is no hope without wrestling with
despair if you afraid of despair you
never have hope what do you when you say
lefse with it you got to wrestle with it
not allow it to have the last word but
you gotta wrestle with it when you're
talking about the your concern about
nuclear catastrophe impending nuclear
catastrophe you're talking about what's
going on right now when Iran
one thing about Russia Russia is US
missile heads Iran north possibility of
war u.s. bombing too precious Iran
Iranian brothers and sisters are as
precious as priceless as anybody
actually just happened to be under an
authoritarian rule that that does need
to be changed and transformed there's no
doubt about it but you think you know
all the hell they've been through many
years when the United States was on the
side of Saddam Hussein yeah and they
were all alone in the world and
much like our Jewish brothers sisters
felt in 1973 they'd already undergone a
genocidal attack one out three president
Jews killed and 73 do their in the world
all by themselves other than the US
Empire you say oh my god who can I rely
on and that brings out the worst in
people the worst in people because it's
all about in-crowd in-group security yes
authoritarian on the inside and
distrustful of the whole world on the
outside and this is why it's so
difficult to have a discussion about
Israeli occupation what our precious
Palestinian brothers and sisters because
to try to be able to cast a light on how
an underdog because that's the history
Jews 2,000 years it's basically underdog
became an oppressor and how they become
top dogs tied to the u.s. top dogs right
now you always have the ginn those
Jewish voices and organization that are
critical of Israeli occupation critical
of any actions of human beings including
Jews that are that need to be calling
the question but it's hard to keep track
of the rich and priceless humanity of
Palestinian brothers and sisters under
occupation second-class citizenship when
it's very clear that Jews have been
duped so viciously treated for 2,000
years in the history of history of the
West as well as the history of the the
Middle East and yet we have a moral duty
to keep track of the preciousness of
pressed Palestinian babies just as we
want to keep track of the preciousness
of Jewish babies when Gaza and Tel Aviv
must have a spotlight in terms of what
those human beings are going through on
both sides of that divide as it were
even given a symmetric relation of power
and that structure of domination called
the occupation I'd say the same thing
about Tibet I'd say same thing about
kami I'd say the same thing about
Western sub-sahara under Moroccan
domination there's so many examples that
we human beings generate
that require our moral and spiritual
witness and our analytical attention and
our artists who can authorize an
alternative even if only for a moment an
alternative
[Applause]